MOST RECENTLY ON JANUARY THE NU
>> Chris: THAT'S WHY THEY HAD
THE KEYS,
CHRIS THAT WE CALL HIM
HE TURNS, HE THE CORNER.
AS RIGID AS THE SECOND PO
FIRST UNIT BACK COME ON THERE,
STILL SOME TIME ON THE CLOCK.
LEAD.
>> Chris: IS
HE GETS ENOUGH AND IT JUST
LASERS THAT UP THE TOP SHDID A
HE KEEPS GOING.
ENDED UP COLLECTING IT AND
GOING FOR A CHANGE.IT WAS A GOO
TARGET
TO, RIGHT NOW.
I HOPE HE IS COLGATE.
>> Willy: FIRST POWER PLAY FOR
STAVROS.EASON.
AT HOME, THE SECOND HALF WILL
TRYING TO WORK THEIR
NASHVILLE, IN A TIGHT BUCKS,
SCHEIFELE, CLOSING IN CLOSER MO
THIS IS A REALLY TALENTED POWER
PLAY.
OVER TO FORSBERGA
PENALTY ON LUKE
TAKES OVER .
>> Chris: WHAT A PLAY,
SAVED.
>> Willy: SAROS, PLAYS OFF
BRANDON IS IN THERE ALONG WITH
JOSI
HEARTS OUT, TRYING TO KILL
TWO POWER-PLAY GOALS NOW FOR
THE JETS.
OFF THE hris: THIS IS WHY, IT I
THE KEY FOR THE GAME.
JAZZ, ABLE TO SEND IT UP THE WO
AND HE PUTS IT IN.